This expression equals the log of base 10 of x squared minus 16. Here's one
logarithm and one expression. Now that's great reasoning if you figured this
one out. You really just want to multiply the x plus four times the x minus 4.
Since we have two logarithms added together with the same base, we just
multiply these two arguments together. So we'll have the log of base 10 of this
entire product. This is a difference of square pattern. A plus B times A minus
B, so we'll know when we multiple we'll get A squared minus B squared. For x
squared minus 16. We also want to be very careful. This might be confusing,
because we're not sure if we're taking the log of base 10 of x squared, or the
log of base 10 of this entire quantity. That's why it's best to use parentheses
when you want to indicate that. Here I would think I am taking the log of base
10 of x squared finding this number and then subtracting 16. But really I
want to take the log of base 10 of this entire number. Whatever x squared minus
16 turns out to be. That's just a word of caution when reporting your final
answers. Be sure you know what you're taking the log of.